[Applaudissements]
à ce moment là j'ai 17 ans je suis à une
adolescente un peu rebelle je suis à
plein de rêves je sais pas exactement ce
que je veux faire demain dans la vie
future
je vis à un peu au jour le jour je suis
à ce moment là enfin je me crois à ce
moment là invincible j'ai l'impression
qu'au à 17 ans rien ne peut m'arriver
le futur est devant moi et et puis les
malheurs il arrive toujours aux autres
n'est pas asseoir j'ai un petit copain à
l'époque magnifique on décide d'aller
faire un barbecue et puis on emprunte le
chemin donc vers le lieu de destination
à ce moment là c'est vraiment une
journée idyllique
il fait très très beau très chaud à la
musique est à fond je me sens vraiment
vraiment heureuse et c'est à ce moment
là que 1 bat ma vie va basculer que ma
vie va changer on sait pas pourquoi ni
comment mais quand on a quand on a
emprunté ce virage on a dérapé et bals
et les seconds se sont transformés en
minute
ça veut dire que j'ai compris au moment
même où on a dérapé que ça allait être
très grave
j'ai fermé les yeux j'ai protégé mon
visage et quand je me suis réveillée et
bien c'était une scène atroce skins et
nori bleus c'est un film d'horreur et à
ce moment là j'avais deux solutions pour
survivre soit je je me coupais de mes
émotions où je devenais folle je perdais
la raison parce que je pense qu'on est
pas personne n'est préparé à voir ce
genre de scène
ce qu'on pensait parfois des films sont
littéralement très loin de la réalité et
donc je décide de me couper de mes
émotions et je développe à ce moment là
un instinct de survie qui me dépasse ça
veut dire que je comprend très vite que
je vais mourir que la mort est là parce
que mon bras est arrachée parce que je
me jette de mon sang et parce que les
ambulances n'arrive pas donc à ce moment
là vous savez que quand on a 17 ans
enfin on al'impression femmes ont en
tout cas j'avais l'impression que papa
papa est toujours là papa est là pour
m'aider je suis protégé et à ce moment
là je me rends compte qu'en fait je suis
moi et moi même je suis face à moi même
et ça veut dire que je dois développer
une force incroyable pour pouvoir
survivre
donc la mort est là et tout ce que je
veux fait juste vivre
donc après 30 minutes
on me dit ok les ambulances sont là donc
je me relâche et quand j'ouvre les yeux
je suis à l'hôpital
et voilà je pars pour l'opération on me
dit t'inquiète pas on va tout faire pour
te remettre tombera t'inquiète pas moi
je veux juste vivre et puis j'ouvre mes
yeux dans cette chambre d'hôpital et
jeux d'eau je vois ma famille je vois
tourner autour de moi et la première
chose dont je vois tout de suite que
j'ai pas que j'ai plus mon bras droit
mais la première chose que je vois dans
les regards de ma famille c'est de la
tristesse c'est waouh c'est ce qui est
arrivé et voilà et est incroyablement
dur mais moi tout ce que je me dis c'est
un méchant view fait ça veut dire que je
me réveille je me dis mais je suis là
mes gars je suis là ça veut dire je peux
toujours aimé je fais toujours
je fais toujours manger parce que
j'adore ça je peux toujours rigoler fin
et elle a très vite en fait je me rends
compte que dans la perception que les
autres ont de moi mais n'est pas la
réalité
ça veut dire que j'ai grandi en me
disant que ce que pensaient maman papa
de moi ou quand les autres me félicite
c'est ce que je suis et en fait là d'un
coup je vois les regards des autres sont
en mode
j'ai une victime bien sûr je suis devenu
handicapé mais moi je vois pas ça comme
ça moi tout ce que je me dis c'est waouh
je vis en fait seulement les problèmes
vont arriver tu comprends à ce moment là
j'étais dans la joie la bonne humeur
sauf qu'à un moment donné retour à la
réalité on rentre chez soi
et ben on a 17 ans et en fait on fait ça
et on dit allez c'est parti
habille toi c'est parti
maki toi et puis écrit ah ok bon sauf
que j'étais droitière tu comprends alors
j'écrivais comme ça et puis c'est des
bêtises 1 mais tu te rends pas compte à
quel point tu fais tout avec tes deux
mains donc juste me faire mais la cgt
l'a ok en fait tout devenait tout
devenait hypra compliqué donc à ce
moment là j'ai la rage
j'ai la rage tu comprends parce que je
comprends pas en fait c'est une
injustice comprends pas pourquoi moi
pourquoi je dois tout recommencer à zéro
pourquoi mais c'est si dur dans mon ego
je suis une jeune fille 17 ans tu
comprends à l'école du lycée c'est on se
savent bien le matin tu vois on y ferait
on né sait pas on est un peu dans cette
perception du look français hyper
important quand et adolescents puis tu
plais les garçons tout ça tout ça tu en
est donc là d'un coup tout tout tout mon
environnement tout va changer en vrai et
là je vais avoir une tout autre réalité
donc dans un premier temps le combat va
être
ben déjà de retrouver ma dignité pour
moi parce que pour moi c'est ma dignité
qui a été prise donc déjà ma dignité de
pouvoir me débrouiller tout seul donc au
départ je mets des heures et des heures
à arriver à faire quelque chose tu vois
que quelqu'un arrive à faire facilement
et après on dit que les gens handicapés
ont quelque chose de moins je vais te
dire que moi ma créativité elle est sans
limite
ah ah ah parce que tout était un défi tu
sais et puis bon et puis bah il faut
affronter une des choses qui est qui est
vraiment très très difficile surtout
quand on est jeune c'est le regard des
gens donc je vais retourner au lycée et
à ce moment là tout ce que je désire
c'est reprendre une vie normale en fait
j'arrive au lycée et waouh c'est comme
dans les films tu sais tout le monde me
regarde avec pitié c'est tout le monde
je je deviens pas un monstre mais je
deviens la halle à l'arrivée en fait
j'arrive à l'école et je parle que de ça
je suis résumer à ça en fait je suis
résumé un handicap et je me dis là ça va
être vraiment difficile parce que tout
ce que je veux c'est de nouveau être
comme avant
et puis physiquement ça va pas du tout
parce que j'ai eu énormément d'opération
ce qui fait que waouh
il faut 16 heures de sommeil pour m'en
remettre
tu vois le truc pire qu'un bébé et donc
c'est vraiment dur et le médecin me dit
un an après parce que bon les médecins
sont gentilles de 10 mais ça valait tu
vas voir dans quelques mois je reviens
après je lui dit écoute ça ne va
toujours pas et il me dit il faudrait
faire un sport un sport pourtant
remettre ça va t'aider
et là je me dis tiens si je testais la
danse pourquoi pas et là j'arrive et tu
sais ça fait comme dans les films
j'ai poussé la porte de l'école de danse
et ça fait
oh et là je me dis ouah j'arrive là et
je vois plein de couleurs plein de gens
plein plein plein de sourires et hier un
truc un dynamisme et je me dis waouh
et en même temps en même temps c'est le
pire jour de ma vie c'est le pire jour
de ma vie pourquoi parce que je sais pas
comment je vais faire en fait ça veut
dire j'arrive là et je me dis comment je
vais réussir à danser un bras je suis
mal dans ma peau je suis pas bien parce
que c'est un corps que je ne connais pas
c'est encore que je n'accepte pas et là
j'arrive et pas forcément j'ai cette
posture d'une victime parce que à ce
moment là je suis une victime
donc j'arrive comme ça et tout ce que je
veux pas arrive c'est à dire je veux pas
qu'on me regarde je veux pas qu'on
regarde mon bras et tout le monde
regarde le bras et tout le monde à cette
question de comment elle va faire pour
dance un bas et là je me dis au revoir
ça va être très très dur donc là je
prends mon premier cours c'est la
catastrophe
je ne suis rien du tout ça veut dire que
le profil enchaîne le truc et moi je
suis là à aa et je me suis jamais y
arriver mais en même temps il ya un truc
qui se passe dans mon corps je sais pas
t'expliquer tu sais quand tu vis une
expérience aussi difficile je pouvais
pas exprimer en mots à quelqu'un ce que
je ressentais
comment tu veux comment tu veux que je
t'explique que je souffre pour moi ce
mot était limitant sa limite est ce que
je ressentais parce que c'était mon
expérience avait été tellement physique
mais par contre fais moi danser une
danse hip hop tu vois toute la rage que
j'avais là d'un coup je me mets en et là
je me dis ouah ça va devenir ma plus
belle histoire d'amour et surtout ce qui
va me sauver la vie ça va devenir pour
moi une vraie thérapie
enfin à ce moment là je suis toujours
super faible et donc après ce premier
jour où ça a été la cata
prof je rentre chez moi et je me dis
comment je vais faire comment je vais
faire pour supporter ça au quotidien
comment je vais faire pour supporter le
regard des gens au quotidien
et là je vais créer un jet li na
angelina est une personne que je vais
créer je me suis dit hé ben tu sais quoi
je vais m'en tire je me crée une
histoire parce qu'au fond finalement on
se raconte des histoires alors au lieu
de me raconter l'histoire d'une fille
qui a eu un terrible accident de voiture
qui a failli mourir tu sais quoi je me
racontais l'histoire de la fille est née
comme ça qui est super bien dans sa peau
c'est faux à l'intérieur de moi c'est
faux mais si je montre pas que j'assume
qui je suis les autres vont me manger
donc le deuxième jour je vais arriver à
cette salle de danse et je vais me
diront matin en me réveillant je suis
bien de ces je m'en fous de ce qu'on dit
ce matin je suis bien au feu et donc je
pusse cette porte en ayant tout de suite
une autre énergie
j'ai une autre énergie je me tiens
différemment et je regarde tout le monde
dans les yeux
et là d'un coup tous les regards qui
était de la pitié de la peau était au
point mort
c'est la bras tout cédé de l'admiration
et en fait j'ai vite compris que ben les
gens ils partaient dans mon histoire et
donc je me suis dit ok je vais en fait
de venir au lieu d'être mon ennemi et me
rejeter je vais essayer de devenir ma
meilleure amie et de voir ce que ça va
donner
si j'essaye au début je mens mais c'est
pas grave parce que tu sais quand tu te
réveilles le matin parfois tu te dis je
vais pas y arriver je suis nul je suis
ceci je suis cela et ben ouais ouais
c'est ce qui arrive chez c'est à force
de trac ôter cette histoire tout ton
corps tout se met en action pour arriver
à ça m'a si tu te dis ah je me réveille
le matin j'assume qui je suis 100% c'est
peut-être faut bien un jour ou l'autre
ça deviendra vrai et puis physiquement à
ce moment là ça va pas encore donc les
médecins me disent écoutez
josée bruneau vous allez devoir avoir un
métier adaptées quatre heures à maximum
de travail par jour et là je me dis ok
donc je pars non le développement
personnel parce que forcément l'être
humain voilà l'être humain me passionne
terriblement et je deviens sophrologue
sauf que j'ai toujours cette passion au
moins tu sais sauf que chaque fois que
je vais prendre un cours de danse il ya
quelque chose qui se passe dans mon
corps et je me dis c'est pas possible
faut que ma vie il faut que que ma vie
deviennent ça et je décide de dépasser
mes limites
ça veut dire je bluesy toute ma vie boum
je dis ok je m'en vais je faire mon
cabinet je coupe tout mes cheveux je me
fais tatouer et je parle los angeles et
là en fait je dépasse mes limites
au fur et à mesure du temps jusqu'à ce
que j'entende parler de ce fameux
casting
ok y'a un casting qui se passe à paris
faut savoir que je suis belle voila
voila moi j'ai pas l'accent mais le
support et j'entends parler de ce fameux
castille et donc on me dit voilà black m
recherche des danseurs pour sa nouvelle
tournée
ok et la première chose que je me dit
c'est ouais mais dans ce cas qu'un bras
quel artiste va prendre une danseuse
taquin bras et ensuite je me dis mais
attend au lieu de voir le verre à moitié
vide
si je le verrai à moitié plein en disant
à mes atouts dans toutes ces nanas ce
jour de casting l'aa
quand je suis arrivée là 150 nana là
mais je suis la sallede comme ça
mais je suis la seule et surtout une
force et si je me disais tu sais quoi
y a personne d'autre que moi j'arrive et
je démonte touché la meilleure parce que
si je pense pas ça si j'arrive pas en
disant je suis la meilleure
j'ai des amis qui arrivait qu'ils disent
c'est une expérience dans ce pas une
expérience vous êtes mignonne là moi
j'arrive si mignonne aussi mais moi je
viens pour me battre
tu comprends moi je suis noir et or je
me lève et je vais me battre
donc je suis arrivé là a vécu une une gt
des terres voilà clairement voilà je
perds mes mots gt2 des terres je suis
arrivée là des terres j'ai regardé black
et toute son équipe soit arrivé je me
suis dit ok angie te laisse pas
déstabiliser
tu sais en moins là ça allait comme ça
mais je me dis le montre pas je les ai
regardés dans les yeux
j'étais tellement déterminé et il ya un
monde un moment donné dans le son le son
fait ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta et
là je me dis c'est quoi mon petit bras à
la jean fils mitraillette
la tata tata tata et là ils sont juste
en mode own words tout le monde se lève
tous m'ont applaudi je me dis ok c'est
parti il a juste eu prise pour partir en
tournée voilà donc on était 150 nana on
était quatre à être prises c'est une
expérience incroyable
on a fait plus d'un an de tournée et
toute la france on est parti à tahiti
fin c'était franchement cette expérience
m'a changé la vie et encore une fois
elle m'a ramené à assat c'est-à-dire
déjà les les limites sont celles qu'on
s'impose pour commencer mais
deuxièmement et si dans ma vie au lieu
d'être toujours toujours et toujours mon
ennemi parce que tu sais quoi dans ta
vie tu seras toujours face qu'à une
seule personne c'est toi même les autres
autour de toi ne sont que le reflet de
ce que tu penses de toi et de tes
croyances et si et si tu te disais hé
ben je vais devenir mahbès fresnes au
lieu de devenir mon ennemi eh ben je
vais faire deux mois ma meilleure
alliés parce que tu sais quoi dans des
moments comme ça il y aura que toi et
toi même et je décide de faire un avec
moi même voilà merci
[Applaudissements]